good morning today as a dream come true
I am inside minecraft I've never done
this before I think I have to play an
earlier version of Minecraft so to keep
the lower intact
this will basically be a fever dream for
me I think oh god oh my god I have steak
I have oh my god how do I see okay cool
whoa
this is so cool how do I eat it eat it
num num num my fall am four can i what
elaborate I missed you
oh my God my slaves everyone is here
this is so awesome
well I miss you so much outside can I
picked you power of llama you look so
happy
my god it's even beautiful there in real
life hey hey hey hey hey hey oh I always
wanted to do this go really close I can
smell them oh they smell like this my
boyfriend I'm so sorry you're a good boy
you're a good boy come in here eat steak
I'm sorry stop eat I'm living a
nightmare
Oh God take this away okay here okay
here omnomnom I'm nom nom om nom he
liked it I'm numb numb numb numb numb
numb numb numb numb yeah again oh my god
you're again you're so beautiful
good dog I mean horse
[Music]
my god jug again my man profesh a fake
okay can I activate this whoa can I
write your this is so awesome I like it
as well oh my god I have my trident
wait let me hold them like this your
again let's freakin ride baby oh yeah I
hear spider I need to kill how do i how
do I throw the training there it is
damn I'm cool yeah
oh he kicked me off really oh I missed
you it's bad give me hug oh you're a
good dog sled why did you leave me oh my
god birch lasagna oh my god IKEA Tower
oh my god it's so big you see this ring
oh wow oh my god I take a knee for my
fallen angels this is so cool it's a
little wonky I'm not using the official
version oh my god can I ride my gaming
chair oh my god I am in my gaming chair
can I be in my gaming chair while I ride
the gaming chair because that will be
the ultimate experience of all time like
this oh it's super light you for you
don't come near me Sven I'm a monster oh
my god can I go up the meatball yes my
dream is coming true
break it down Sven you're not supposed
to be here do I dare to jumps then of
course wait how do I jump ahead you're
crazy oh he's fine here we go
that was our jobs then I catch you ha
wow I swim so faster than we are this is
so cool
oh my first hey man what's up
I miss you so much you're such a good
boy oh wait can I use the bow like I put
it in I just dragged in her oh it's
working it's working ok let's kill the
villagers oh it's hard to aim I almost
got him back to work coward
come on yeah we got him spend spend this
ecstatic that was upper hey this is so
cool Bengt I missed you as well
good dog good give me that give me that
back take it off oh thank you
bad dog bad dog better look at me cutely
bad dog I'm leaving Oh actually let me
look at the flip chamber the friction
rings er oh my god ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding work
work
oh my god I always wanted to do this
alright you what do you sell nothing
you're useless
hey listen to me listen to me listen to
me
don't run away from me listen to me
you're garbage
you're trash listen to me you're trash
you're absolute trash garbage
like Squidward what is this tiny bit be
are you afraid you're afraid look at me
in my eyes
good night gamer does this not work hey
hey I'm talking to you that's right
good night gamer oh no you disappeared
crazy right
he just disappeared so crazy another one
disappeared so crazy Wow
strange have life work alright let's not
fall in the trap hey hey hey hey what's
up aren't you freaking huh I need you
guys to cooperate a little bit I need
you to Frank there we go guys that's
right keep freaking come on how does
this look like for you guys hey Frank
nice enough you've all had enough up oh
my god I almost fell in trap
alright guys come on it's time I want to
see a baby I don't have old bay come on
you how do you see me don't be shy don't
be shy go ahead freak alright I'll come
back and I expect to see Ben Ben time to
go to sleep good night gamers whoa
Micra oh my god the maple is so
beautiful considered water shape of
course they must still be here Council
of water sheep you're still here the
Council of water she must be stopped
if I did this sooner don't look at me
Jurgen don't look at me if I'd done that
sooner then maybe bad things would have
been happening yes Fred
should we go through the nether wow this
is so cool
reexpansion everything oh my lord I'm
not sure but I think this save file I'm
playing on it's like right before I beat
the ender dragon how do I run my god it
tastes so good I wish I could live in
mine crunch this is so much better oh my
god okay I haven't mine in my car yet
whoa the power of being alive look at
this this is so cool
I am such a child and I don't care
where's the portal to the end this is it
yeah this is not making me sick
oh it is does that mean people pool boys
here people will you Steve you absolute
scumbag
how could you leave me like that huh
what's up with that hey babe elbow baby
babe elbow you know what I'm gonna push
you in this time don't talk to me like
that how do I push you in can I put
water and push you in I'm writing peepee
poo-poo I didn't even mean to do this
oh my god I've never felt so powerful as
a human being go pee pee suppose I don't
think I have the rod to command him
people do not go into lava how do I jump
there we go don't go near there it's not
safe
damn this looks so crazy in VR my mine
is tripping right now I want to push you
dummy you dummy thick come on damn oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah baby I'm sorry I'm
sorry I just jumped Viper don't ever
talk to me again oh my god the ender
dragon Oh
how in the world oh my god this is
terrifying
Oh God now hey wait oh no I'm fine
drop top it's so creepy in VR seriously
I don't know this is so cool okay so I
think now I am in shift mode
I think I'm crawling now so now I
shouldn't be able to fall over okay cool
this is just as exciting as it always
been building bridges never gets easier
Oh God that is terrifying in the air oh
yes oh god don't look at them sup guys
ah we're cool right
alright let's see if I can do this yeah
I almost got it
oh it's so much harder to judge the
distance
[Music]
[Music]
why did I think this was a good idea
yeah
this this is like that one meme and I'm
the girl okay well that was a terrible
idea
oh my god they frickin it Pepe yes
excuse me excuse me
hello hey hey hey hey oh you want to
jump on bed oh he loves me
hey don't look at me like that oh oh
we're having epic time I'll tell you
I'll kill you one day enough today keep
walking think they maintaining keep
working so much more real to tell people
up in VR you know it feels better I
don't know what it is chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop okay so
then I forgive you for killing banks
it's okay
because I killed elaborate death why is
no one doing my crops what is this hey
Dean there my god he loves me
come on spin I missed you so much today
you were like a father to me can you
hurry up Jesus we can pluck flowers Finn
were you always this slow look look this
one is for you cuz I love you bling
blong he loves air yeah oh so I hold
down to use the shield that's so cool
isn't that right fan hey let's go kill
cows like you always like give Q yeah
they my mister Trident so much okay so
when you kill sorry sheep oh my god they
die too quickly with this I need a
weaker target this one kill this one
kibbutz van kill it
yeah good dog give the chicken oh my god
is too cute I can't kill it
Sven will do it good job saying
incredible job yeah that's my spam dub
dub dub dub dub dub dub dub doctor what
you spent this how rambo-style
damn I swear I'm shooting to his right
but yeah there it is look at the beam of
power of IKEA it's so glorious with the
glorious day we live in Sven what the
glorious world everything is happy and
peaceful and you definitely do not leave
me
then you hear this you see that a bunch
of sheeps here lick got'em dumb sheep
you're dumb you're so dumb sheep isn't
that right Sven Sven agrees Kirsten I
love you so much I'm gonna give you some
snacks snacks snacks
oh it's getting dark we better head back
home spent don't worry I will defend you
at all cost
it's not shooting where my crosshair is
it's shooting to the right of it I don't
even Tom oh god what was that stupid Pig
[Music]
Sven though you could have got killed
oh god it's another one no go away oh my
god he blocked my strongest attack I'll
never mind I hate them
man IKEA Towers so beautiful it makes me
carry ID oh it's so cool to see your own
world in VR I love it can activate the
farm Wow look at all those potatoes bro
it's truly inspiring me truly giving me
strength nice swim
kind of want to try it son you need to
be safe then their bone no I'm coming
you missed me didn't get in their bones
I know you did you dirty dirty yeah this
is so weird
yeah oh no I'm drowning ah don't not
like this how could you come here what
song can i play yeah ah oh yeah oh yeah
no no well this has been an interesting
episode to say the least
c'mere Smith he's coming he's a little
slow his song is fire and I ride in my
car
[Music]
hey child kill it no said dad hated it
hated it I don't care if it's a dream I
don't care oh say come here please
my suckling child is finished I love you
me but I gotta go I don't know what I
did for you to leave me but it's okay I
can't I want to leave my beautiful
meatball I want to leave you sleep but I
gotta oh my god it's like I'm actually
hugging said I can feel you
I can smell him but he smells so bad you
smell like real dogs friend what is this
you nuts man go away sure thank you guys
for watching this episode if you enjoyed
be our minecraft smash like and if you
enjoyed in general by epic merch and if
in general you like things in general
subscribe bye bye well you haven't tried
to person later citizen II after 50
million outros flash down just down it's
still relevant just down a bit